funny thing is I guess there is a
lawsuit for universal using the dark
universe logo because Justice League
dark calls it the dark universe or
something like that beginning in this
movie dark universe logo showed up I was
like well [ __ ] you lawsuit I admire the
commitment I do a mummy so The Mummy
stars Tom Cruise it's not only a
retelling of the story of the moment but
it's chapter one and Universal launching
their dark universe their Cinematic
Universe for their monsters that's the
mummy Dracula jekyll-and-hyde Creature
from the Black Lagoon The Invisible Man
etc etc this is chapter 1 here and in
the beginning of this movie Tom Cruise
and his friend they're ultimately
scavengers or grave robbers they're just
looking for treasures looking for money
and they unearth this mummy and the
mummy comes to life and now the mummy
has a plan funny thing though in the
beginning of this movie I was like oh my
god it hit me this is the Uncharted
movie we haven't gotten yet in that I
instantly was like I was rivers going to
be cool even Tom Cruise is a bit Nathan
Drake is it was actually falling in line
for me then the movie keeps going in it
is certainly chapter 1 in the setup of
the cinematic universe starting out the
movie has some cool stuff I mean anytime
something crashed it was awesome that
can't make a good movie but the Mummy's
chasing after them you're having fun I
feel like this movie wants to be this
super awesome dark tone however it has
comedy woven into this movie that
doesn't actually land for the town it's
super serious until it's super not this
kind of comes across as conflicting like
near the beginning of this movie there's
this dude that Tom Cruise literally
knows and he has to shoot him because
you know like to possess and do the
thriller thing at first it's like I'm
sure to go shoot him he accidentally
shoots him then he shoots him again and
then then he makes a joke and gives a
gun back a guy and oh well it's over I
guess you're not gonna mint that okay I
guess no one cares I guess you don't
care talking about Tom Cruise the dude
is perpetually on cruise control and
whatever he's in he commits and he does
a good job in here not only is he still
now an action star I knew that from the
last Mission Impossible movie this
shouldn't surprise us at this point the
guy can still run and haul ass against
the best of them even when the best of
them is a big cloud of saying Russell
Crowe is dr. Jacqueline this movie is
more or less than Nick Fury you tell he
in his organization there's a central
piece but this movie does do the thing
where it has to explain what's going on
a lot like a few times for the set up
its finds like this happened
thousands of years ago and this is why
this mummy ladies bad but someone also
stop and be like I think this is what
happened and then this this this and
this what can this and now bad things
are coming they're like that's a lot of
explanations like when characters do
that movies what's happening is they're
telling the other character but really
they're telling the audience and really
this movie felt like it had to choose
what it was it's either a standalone
mummy movie or it's chapter one in the
dark universe it can't be both I guess
it could be both and it really is
technically both but it really commits
more to the dark universe thing rather
than the standalone mummy movie really
this is the Tom Cruise show featuring
the moment I get when you have an actor
like Tom Cruise you want to concentrate
on him most maybe that means you
shouldn't have gotten Tom Cruise for a
mummy movie and again if you didn't get
Tom Cruise for a mummy movie people
probably wouldn't care enough to go see
another running movie in either case
they're probably going to go watch
Wonder Woman this weekend anyway it
doesn't matter and about halfway through
the movie after the movie the concept of
visuals that L ceased to be new movie
slows down a bit more than a church but
it is an interesting chapter one and you
are like I do want to see what happens
going forward in this universe I'm
interested it for nothing else but as a
mummy movie the movie kind of fell they
use world-building exposition to build
the cinematic universe they're going for
but in doing so sacrificed a cohesive
plot for the movie at hand you got a
deal with the movie at hand first and
foremost so the dark universe interests
me I feel like it would anyway because I
like monsters in the end I will say The
Mummy would probably be a better time if
I were drunk yeah no it's a party where
those zombies in the movie doing the
Thriller dance I had to laugh because I
couldn't help but think of it when
they're all walking they're like alright
guys so the mummy are you going to see
it what are you hoping for here whatever
you want to see whatever you're hoping
for comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]